Unpassionate about positive thinking
from the early books written the power
of positive thinking and all the experts
in the past.
Many of them,
I knew them later on in life,
met them in different parts of the
world,
but I,
I apply it because if you study any of
the writings and the tissues of positive
thinking,
you have to have a goal in your mind.
Otherwise you're thinking blindly.
You don't walk in and you don't walk to
a destination without having an idea of
what you're going,
where you're going.
So it's positive thinking isn't just
thinking to yourself,
well,
I can do anything I want and so forth
because some things we can't do.
I,
I have some people I know personally.
I wish they felt they could float if
they walked out of an airplane in the
sky.
No,
I'm not being nasty.
I'm just being crazy.
But the real positive thinking is having
goals because a,
a golfer never hits a ball and so he
sees where it's going.
Never hits a ball and police sees words.
Otherwise it's going.
Neither does a picture when he throws a
ball.
So we have to have in our lives some
direction and we have to think with,
with the positiveness that we're going
to take advantage of all the
opportunities that lead to that
direction.
But the interesting thing is when
failures take place and study the lives
of famous people,
they found alternative routes which
often caused them to invent new
machinery,
new paraphernalia that didn't work when
the other thing failed because they had
to be resourceful.
The same as you are in a war.
When you're playing a game in which
you're playing against a team and
something goes wrong.
It's the same.
Life is really a game show.
You have to,
you have to have a flexibility and those
things take place.
Not only in knowing in your heart and
soul,
you're going to find a route.
You're going to find the root to this
place you want to go to,
whether it's working in a,
in a,
uh,
a large food complex because you like to
cook and what have you and your say food
or whether it's working on a sports team
or what have you.
But you also have to figure,
you know,
if this thing doesn't happen,
maybe there's something in the
background there that I didn't notice
that I could take advantage of in the
same way that sometimes.
And let's take a lesson from chefs.
If they don't have a certain
piece,
a certain appetizer that's,
that's there for that food,
there's often a couple of other ones
that can be edit that turns out,
can make it a new chased,
a new dessert.
And that's the way you have to think
about like as a meal at your adding to.